Brandon schlichter is the ultimate rags
to Rich's story as a child he was
evicted from his home instead of going
to college he got a job at a warehouse
earning minimum wage and for years he
was barely scraping by however over time
he was able to turn that experience into
a multi-million dollar fortune and now
he owns and operates laundromats rental
real estate vending machines and even a
car wash that generates a combined
several million dollars a year so today
we're diving into exactly how he did it
to the best side hustles that you could
start to make money in 2023 and the
realities of running several businesses
on today's episode of subscribe if you
haven't done that already although
before we go into that we gotta thank
our sponsor streamyard producing a video
can be a very daunting task especially
for those who haven't done it yet before
yeah for the people I've spoken to it's
the editing and post-production process
that discourages a lot of people the
most especially in the very beginning
but thankfully streamer offers a
comprehensive solution for live
streaming production enabling users to
effortlessly transmit live videos to
popular platforms such as YouTube
Facebook and twitch with stream yard you
could easily create high quality live
streams with just a few clicks and
they're easy to use interface makes it
incredibly easy to get started you can
create your own custom backgrounds add
multiple cameras and even add guests
with just a few clicks streamer also has
powerful analytics tools that helps you
understand just how well your live
streams are performing you're also able
to see how many people are watching your
live streams and Which social media
platforms are driving the most amount of
traffic plus they integrate with popular
streaming and analytics tools like OBS
Google analytics and YouTube Creator
studio so feel free to try stream yard
for free today using the link Down Below
in the description and you can get
started creating professional looking
live streams in minutes again the link
is down below in the description thank
you so much and let's get on with the
episode free so welcome to the iced
coffee hour Brandon schlichter we are so
excited to have you also known as
investmentjoy and you put out some
incredible content I've been watching
for a very very long time thank you for
coming well thank you for having me here
it was just by absolute random
happenstance that I ended up here
because yeah we got to tell you what
happened so I went to what Sushi Neko in
Las Vegas for all you could eat sushi
last night and I walk in and guess who's
there you're kidding no that it was by
that coincidence yes
really because he asked me he was like
hey what's that Sushi Spot I'm in Vegas
where am I supposed to go is it it's
called Super Sushi right and I'm like
yeah super Sushi's great but recently
we've been going to Sushi Neko so you
should try that spot out he's like okay
I'll go there instead and he went there
and then you went that same night oh my
gosh yeah we walked in you had just sat
down yeah and uh and now we're here but
he told me he told me that he texted you
Jack and uh to let to let me know that
he was in town and he didn't let me know
did you say that exactly yeah I said I I
said I'm in town if you and Graham have
time let's hang out or you want to go to
get dinner let's go get dinner whatever
and uh you were on a well I thought you
had left the state already and you're
you're Mr important you I'm not I'm just
bad at getting don't you have Graham's
number you have his number
I feel like here's the thing with with
graham I feel like you were have been
the filter for Graham and I should go to
no go go straight to no yeah
he's getting better I don't know what
he's doing here well anyways guys
conversation right back to our guests
okay how much in real estate do you own
at the moment um like straight real
estate if we wouldn't assign like any
value to my businesses it's probably six
seven million dollars ish six seven
million dollars what age uh 37 37 that's
pretty good yeah but what makes it
unique though is I think the laundromats
yeah I absolutely love your tick tocks
and shorts where you go through and you
you go through the laundromat and you
collect the change and then you add up
how much you made that day there's
something about it that I find
incredibly interesting yeah I mean it's
one of those things where I'm just
trying to show people my life like oh
Brandon does these things this is how
much I make I'm really trying to be
transparent and honest with people
because it's like
um I I have great days it's like before
I got on the airplane because I'm trying
to get out of the mode of me being the
guy that does most the work and
um since the last time I was on the show
I've hired a lot of people but I'm not
there yet I'm down like last time I was
like at four or five hours a week now
I'm down to one or two hours a week at
the laundromat and I'm trying to get
just stop like do my videos there show
the revenue numbers and then go on to
something bigger I'm trying to do bigger
things more profitable things because I
I've been like one of the weird things
is I've been recording like everything
I've done in business since 2013. so I
can go on my photo roll on Android and
like oh here's the house we're fixing
floors on you know almost 10 years ago
this right and it's just like I want
people to see progress in what I'm doing
but I also want to be honest so like
right before I got on that airplane we
pulled like 26 2700 out of the
laundromat it's like oh gosh this would
be a good video man look at this big I
mean the stack of bills is this tall
it's like I went back and watched one of
my first videos and it was I had 148
dollars in quarters in the first
collection back in uh
June July 2019 and now it was
26 years so most of what you do now with
the laundromat you just go in and
collect money because that's what I'm
seeing like everywhere on social media
like tens of millions of views you just
going in taking out the quarters
collecting it it's just some absurd
amount of dollars is it really that easy
my thinking is if it's that easy
everyone's gonna do it yes and it's like
for if you were an established investor
if you someone of your caliber or Jax
caliber or Alex's caliber it really you
it would be that easy you guys
understand business you understand money
and finance you've got some level of
money so you any of the problems that
would come up you can pay for systems
you could pay out for automations you
can pay for people to do the work for
you you could hire a competent manager
operator and then you do whatever you
want and that's where I'm really trying
to be but I've gone from 2019 I had like
two employees two people working for me
in between YouTube and all these other
businesses we probably gosh I got
probably 40 people working for me at
this point 40 at probably at this point
yeah it just keeps getting more and more
and I keep one to hire
more people how are you able to afford
40 employees
um you YouTube blessed me in 2022 my
channel Revenue was up pretty good
um the real estate company did about 1.3
1.4 million in sales we sold some some
houses I'm trying to reposition my
portfolio sell off all my really low end
stuff and just go up to Mid Thai class
I'm still staying in Ohio still in the
same two counties that I've been in just
trying to change some things in my
business because I I feel like I've
documented every disaster in low-end
housing that you could I've dealt with
drugs I've dealt with violence I've
dealt with rats crawling out of trash
bags just everything and I'm like okay
this has been my life to this point but
what's it look like as an investor and a
business owner as I transition and I get
rid of that portfolio I'm going to go
negotiating a deal on my little 28 worst
and the offer that came in gosh right
before I came to Vegas it's like 1.4
1.04 1.05 million dollars
which is nothing here in Vegas but I
probably have 300 000 in that so my
portfolio is almost tripled and I was
like well if I can get my headache I can
alleviate these headaches with these low
end rentals
um I've got an option feeler out I might
Finance part of the portfolio take a
bunch of a decent bit of money up front
finance a large portion of that 1.05 at
current interest rates I offer I think
8.5 percent to a potential buyer and I
was like okay so I I take off my
headaches I put a big lump of cash in my
pocket and then I go on I start
acquiring better places because we just
we just finished up this beautiful
Victorian house downtown I'll rent it
probably to a doctor or a lawyer and
that's a different clientele than I've
dealt with sure for the most part I've
got those people now I've always had
those people but I they don't make good
YouTube videos and I've never been able
to like figure out how do I script this
as time goes on
it's easy to script it's easy to tell a
story about you know the sing the single
mom that you're working with and who's
looking for affordable housing and
here's I helped them out their way I've
put out a lot of stories about that on
you know long format short format
content and now it's like okay I think
I'm at a point where I can tell the
story about myself and these properties
a little bit better so now we're
transitioning on to bigger and better
things let's talk about because what
you've built is pretty incredible like
between the YouTube channel the real
estate portfolio the laundromat
businesses all the businesses that you
own can we talk about where you started
and how you were able to acquire this
amount of like assets and businesses how
far do you want to go back what's what
sparked off the journey being poor okay
let's start that I grew up poor uh my
dad was a truck driver my mom sold Avon
we were evicted twice growing up um that
was pretty hard
um when my dad had a heart attack when I
was 18 years old so had to go work at a
warehouse and
um when I was 15 I was really big into
the sport of paintball if you guys have
ever played it and it was like that's
especially back then it's cheaper now I
really want to get back into it because
it's like all right number one I have
the money and it's also like a third of
the cost so a quarter of the cost so I
was like this is really cool I want to
do this but how do you make any money
for it and it's like well I can't get a
job at 15 years old but I could start an
online store so my brother and I started
like essentially an online pawn shop and
we still bought and sold people's
paintball guns and we got to the point
we were we were buying selling trading
making 40 bucks an hour at 15 years old
were you flipping like fixing up buying
fifths yeah buying buying flipping
fixing and like I have no mechanical
knowledge no one in my immediate family
was mechanically fine but my brother and
I were just like we couldn't read a
manual fix things so we did at that time
making 40 bucks an hour but I had no
understanding of finances like nothing I
like I'm a I was a d average student and
as far as
um algebra goes and algebra is really
critical to business you need to know
how to calculate numbers together you
need to know how they correlate and I
didn't realize at 15 years old I was
fixing paintball guns making 40 bucks an
hour wasn't fun but if I knew that I was
making that much money I would have
probably I would have had a million
dollar company at 50 probably 17 years
old before my dad's heart attack which
that would have been life-changing for
me at that point if I had gone that way
but I didn't so then my brother and I
got into this mobile paintball business
thing where we would go and take a
trailer full of paintball equipment to a
church facility or a youth camp or
whatever and hey you can rent all my
paintball equipment for fifteen hundred
two thousand dollars I made minimum wage
like you you guys critically review the
businesses that you do and you you can
figure out how much money am I making
per hour is this the most optimal way
for me to make the money and I didn't I
was making three bucks an hour doing the
thing that was fun
but I we just totally threw away the
business that was making money you
weren't able to recognize that
discrepancy nope between income no like
I mean what happens when you don't track
your profit expenses you just look is
there money in the account yes or no so
you just found something else that you
enjoyed doing a lot more and you went
that route because it was still money
yeah because it was good money it was 16
17 years old forgot my driver's license
and we were towing a truck around
southern Ohio Michigan at that point we
just never thought about it because oh
it's fun every life's great you know got
up to 17 18 years old started thinking
well you know we're not really making
much money here maybe we should do
something no we're super passionate
about this you know passion will cover
us soon dad had a heart attack and then
I had to go work at the warehouse I was
like oh crap that dream's over today
like that's this summer was the summer
of O3
um that dream's over and I gotta go into
something Reading in a warehouse I was
packing people's clothes for The Gap
it's a distribution facility so that's
why I will never say anything bad ever
to anybody that works at a warehouse
like Amazon that's exactly what I did
was I was getting making 11.25 an hour
packing people's underwear and clothes
um at one point I did start running a
forklift so that was that was I love
driving a foreign so it was fun but I I
you know I knew at that point I had to
do something else it's like I can't make
1125 an hour I want to get married we
would love to have kids someday you know
18 years 19 years old think about the
future you can't do that at 11 bucks an
hour it's like what could what I do what
can I do in Southern Ohio I have no
college education I don't know anything
like what where do I go it's like you
know everybody in town that's in real
estate seems to be driving a Cadillac
they've got a suit on and I thought
those are the rich people so I got my
real estate license put my hondros
college thing I was in real estate
school for three weeks but 13.50 on a
credit card I'll get my real estate
license and I did and it uh wasn't great
early on but the where my life split
apart and I went on a different path
from understanding my profit and loss
sheet for my paintball business I went
another route and I started being around
people who were wealthy and never been
around anybody that ever talked about
money and said oh I actually have money
and like the first within two years of
me being real estate I met a truck
driver just like my dad who drove for GM
out of Columbus he was buying and
flipping houses with cash in 06 so
before the bubble burst he used to live
in houses with cash and I was like how
can you afford this and he said well I
got an investing I took my money coming
in from driving a truck and I invested
it and that built up cash reserves and I
decided after a while I'm going to tap
into my cash reserves I'm going to flip
some houses and he started flipping some
houses and they made money and they made
more money how'd you do this and then I
met another guy that was a janitor and
he bought some houses in one of the
worst neighborhoods of Columbus Ohio for
cash bought them for like 10 or 20 grand
back in 0304 neighborhood better he
improved the location sold them for a
couple hundred thousand dollars a piece
he's like I want you to find me a house
with a pool
gosh you're janitor and you're having
hiring me as a real estate agent to to
find a house for the pool for you it was
mind-blowing because people were just
like the people I grew up with but they
all had money I was like okay this is
what I got to do and I didn't have any
broke investors coming to me but I broke
real estate agents in the office guys we
had a really sweet couple but they were
crying one time that their social
security letter only increased half a
percent that year wow yeah and I was
like you've been a real estate they were
in real estate at that point by for 40
years 40 40 years and they had the
plaques on their wall they have one on
like the MGM or something here in Vegas
and they were overlooking the strip and
they had their you know Columbus board
of realtors jackets on 10 million dollar
Award winner they got these plaques of
when they hit 50 million dollars in
gross sales in 1990. I'm like gosh what
happened they they gambled
they spent every time they had and I'm
like these people were in this real
estate illustrious real estate business
multi-millionaire not multimeter
multi-million dollar producing agents
and they didn't do anything with it and
at that point I kind of developed a
really Mentor mentee relationship with a
guy that was a a CEO of an oil company
he took me in aside he's like God he's
like Brandon unless you really start
learning about money and finance and
running a business and taking care of
yourself he's like that's gonna be you
so he was a CEO of an oil company yeah
how do you just casually run into a CEO
of an oil company like that's gonna be
like a pretty big it is he retired he
retired as the CEO of this oil company
and they dealt with a lot of real estate
Acquisitions at one time they own the
most Subways in Southern Ohio they owned
25 or 26 uh either Citgo or 76 gas
stations and he had to work with
commercial real estate agents he worked
with franchise operations because they
bought they they put Subways in every
gas station they had back in the 90s and
they just printed cash and uh he got out
and he said you know all
you do you have your license still uh no
I don't know I apologize to yeah if this
is not edited out of the conversation he
said those real estate agents are the
laziest stupidest people I've ever met I
wonder if I can do better than they can
and so at 70 years old he got a real
estate license and he beat the heck out
of everybody in the office yeah he was
top 10 agent in my county and like two
years after getting a license and he
just was like he was always talking
about stuff and granted I was the
youngest agent in the office like the
youngest full-time sure there were a
couple part-time agents and they just
know whatever song but I was in the
office every day taking floor time doing
cold calls and I don't know he admired
my hustle and he just really started
talking to me a lot about what I needed
to do and he was always encouraging me
get get into rentals he's like it's hard
to lose with Thrones he's like I'd love
to see you get a brokerage license
someday I never did that because in the
state of Ohio you have to have a college
degree for him and never never can't you
get around that with uh experience they
say you can but I've tried asking guys
at the high division real estate and
they're like hell you got to have to
make a really strong case for us by the
time I was like really going down that
path it was after
I'd got into investing and once I got
into real estate investing was over it
was like why why bother I buy first
house I bought I bought for twenty three
thousand dollars it's full mold we fixed
the mold problem put
25 000 in it it booked it gosh 120 550
000 so I I I I
doubled if not tripled the value we had
in the first house I bought in 2013. how
old were you 26 27 you're 26 27 how much
money you were making as a real estate
agent this is after I I was gosh I was
only making ten thousand dollars a year
as a real estate agent then because I
had started buying and selling websites
and flipping them when I got into
full-time real estate investment so how
much were you making just in general
from active income active income from
Real Estate at the time
oh gosh at that point that year was I
had a really bad stretch from oh 2010 to
2012. terrible year for real estate
agent it was yeah I wasn't making
anything real estate I was doing a lot
of bpos Bank uh sorry Burger price
opinions for foreclosures I was in I
figured out between 2010 and 2012 I did
1400 bpos for banks wow yeah yeah so and
how did that did they just pay you per
person yeah per house how much was that
45 to 75 for those that don't know
basically what that is is when a bank
wants to list a property that they own
that they did a foreclosure on they'll
go to the broker and they'll pay for a
broker price opinion and they'll just
get a whole bunch of those and then say
okay well based on these five Brokers
the average comes in at a hundred
thousand dollars and therefore we'll
list our home at 98. they just make sure
because the banks aren't going and like
finding people in each you know the
banks aren't really going they were
doing an appraiser no they just go to
the actual program because the average
appraisal is gonna be 500 bucks in Ohio
and they can get a real they can get a
guy starving for 50 bucks and they could
yeah they could basically get 10
opinions for the price of one yeah and
also the Brokers had a better pulse on
the market because appraisers will look
at past sales and at that time every
sale was lower than the previous you
couldn't look at past data you have to
look at like what's on the market what's
actually selling how many buyers are
interested a broker is going to give you
I think one of the most honest means out
there if they truly have no skin in the
game yeah and that's what I did for
about two years there started building
some websites in the background that
started making me more money so 2013-ish
came around I was like gosh dang it I
need to get in like investing because I
all the investors like I had I dealt
with were doing great numbers
so I build a chain of websites and sold
them all for one year worth of Revenue
so I was doing like 50 000 as a
take-home pay but building websites
selling selling content on them and
whatnot and sold that the websites I
developed for 50 Grand which is one year
worth of Revenue and uh it was like you
know I'm gonna go out and take 25 000 I
want to find a house to buy I started
mentioning to people online it's like I
want to do this because I'm in Ohio and
just like a lot of people started saying
well you want some money I'll give you
some money I got some money for you if
you want to buy some house with me okay
I just never thought of that I never
thought about actually ever asking
somebody for money and it's just like I
bought that first house started posting
about it on forums and stuff and they
went nuts and they're like okay how much
money do you need and I started talking
to people online that that specific
point they just all become a lot of them
become overnight rich with Bitcoin and
they had they were liquidating their
their Bitcoin after it hit 100 and uh
dollars 100 Bitcoin this back in the day
this 2013. wow and they they sold their
Bitcoin it's like we got to put in
something stable something with some
real upside Brandon it's like uh go buy
some dummy houses with me in Southern
Ohio so they did and I just like boom I
had 400 000 in a fundraiser or a hundred
thousand how do you go and get that big
of a reputation to get four hundred
thousand dollars from nothing was just
your networking as a real estate agent
people just trusted your opinion with
social media in fact I mean you look at
YouTube and and and Facebook and Tick
Tock and stuff and we've got oh we've
got it's video content 2012 2013 and
before is web forms you put us on a web
form you're like oh gosh no here's a
house I bought for 50 Baht and fixed up
for fifty thousand dollars and now we're
bringing a thousand dollars a month
worth of rent off of it plus um it's I
could sell it tomorrow for 120 25 you
get attention from people and you know
they just start throwing money at you
and that's like you know anybody in the
social media Creator space and you guys
have creators on all the time you could
pitch a wood coaster say oh I gotta got
it my only fans logo on the coaster here
and I saw a thousand of them overnight
and it's just the winner that was
smaller back then but it wasn't it's
structural wise it wasn't any different
so this got into investing and it got to
the point around 2017 I was just like
you know why even bother guys I'm like
it was so easy for me to go and get a
deal I'm gonna start doing fun deals so
start running to laundromats I hope I
should buy one of those and then what
sparked the laundromat I uh it's the
it's the one that I do all the videos on
the one in Chillicothe and
um I ran in a buddy of mine said hey we
got to look at the laundromat you want
to have her sandwich money to make and
so we met this older lady
um uh I talk about her on my channel a
lot her son died he owned the laundromat
that's the only job I think he had he
operated the laundromat owned it since
1983 he passed away in 2015 2016. and um
she was telling me that and this buddy
that came along that she had operated
the the son's laundromat she couldn't
run the business because they were doing
eight thousand dollars a month in
quarters and it was just too heavy
physically
I was like what the crap and you know
I'm a real estate guy I'm like this is a
sixty thousand dollar building it was a
dump
and I was like eight thousand dollars a
month in a dumpy location and there's
apartments and I was like I have to buy
this business so we we offered the lady
UH 60 grand for it and she turned us
down and she accepted some of the guys
offer
long story short the some other guy
ended up giving it to I found this out
on me and I think we did YouTube videos
about it he ended up giving the business
to his like 14 year old son as a fun
summer project
and you know no offense 14 year olds if
you're watching this it's you you can't
run a laundromat unless you're super
Castle so they end up having homeless
problem drug problems equipment breaking
down it's like you know you have a 14
year old kid and he got his mom help
trying to help him it's like it's just
it didn't work so they closed it down it
was empty for a couple years and I
negotiated a seller finance deal with
the new guys just just give it to me so
I started getting in just creative deals
just for fun I've done I started getting
into Master leasing homes you guys now
was that laundromat the first one you
did what was the first laundry the first
laundromat with these two absolute dogs
that I finally got rid of
um so I I ran into that laundromat that
was making eight thousand dollars a
month I have to be in the laundry
industry I have to get in the laundromat
industry and this guy contacted me
because he was a part of our investor
Association he said I've got two
laundromats you have to buy them we're
like he was like I was looking five
thousand dollars a month on two
locations before we closed them down so
oh gosh I'll go cash for them right now
so I paid him like 40 or 50 grand for
these two locations they weren't worse
areas than the one I looked at and the
one under the bridge so if you guys
watch me on YouTube I'll referred to as
a lot of men under the bridge we went in
there and turned the electric on just to
do our due diligence phase like an idiot
I bought him without I bought that those
locations on inspection idiot move so
what do you inspect is it the machines
machine machines roof building or no you
do the normal real estate stuff okay and
then you test the equipment you test the
infrastructure like the do the drains
all drained do they does the electric
work work does the electric work really
well all this different stuff and we
looked in the basement there was old
panel
just an old electric panel in there and
uh we didn't think much of it and I and
the lights were on I didn't call my crew
in to do the inspection I just did it
myself an idiot move and uh we got in
there after buying it we flipped on the
windbreaker oh none of the washers and
dryers are powered we flip on the other
breaker and it's a 240 volt line so like
240 volt 60 amp 100 amp is way more the
whole line exploded almost burn it down
wow yeah those are pretty YouTube days
that would have been a really fun video
um they just it caused so much damage in
there we never got it up and running
um so you lost how much money on that oh
gosh 30 000 40 000. it sucks okay yeah
but yeah this seller were they aware of
these things
and it was now but then it falls on you
for just not yeah doing your answer
isn't that disclosed in the in the
seller disclosure and the commercial
real estate in the state of Ohio does
not require a seller disclosure
statement so they could just say well I
don't know it's not in the Forum so I'm
not responsible wow wouldn't that be
worth arguing that they should have
known about that as a business owner
yeah I I it would be but um I'm in small
town Ohio and I'm willing to eat forty
thousand dollars on a bad deal to
maintain a relationship with somebody
especially since they're in our investor
Association I felt like
I had been transparent about everything
and everybody saw that I got screwed
over and I don't think anybody's ever
done business with that guy again so you
can't uh was it get blood from a turnip
the statement one from the stone yeah
it's like he he we had to go negotiate a
short sale on those properties and he
was at a dire financial situation so
really what what am I gonna get from the
guy go take his car yeah okay that's
true yeah so it is what it is I learned
sadly a lot but but why jump in why buy
another one wouldn't that discourage you
and say wow yeah Bad Business well yeah
I had a lot of people I've had a lot of
people really question my sanity at that
point but the problem was I had seen the
income from the one that I have in the
laundromat I'm like gosh dang it that
one was making money I know it I saw two
five gallon buckets where the quarters
up in that the upper the bedroom up
there I'm like I know that place makes
money and I did more due diligence I
actually looked at their water reports
and made sure they had nominal water
usage for the revenue amounts and that's
one like dirty little secret you go and
you ask for the seller to give you a
water statement you figure out their
sale their water usage so I did did a
lot more due diligence on that was like
okay it actually makes money here's the
revenue numbers before they close down
so I felt pretty confident in going into
it and it's been pretty good we're ever
since I put new machines in it just
keeps going up and up up and up and
um we're doing getting ready to do
commercial laundry drop off
um we got got a contract with the
largest Airbnb guy in Southern Ohio and
um we're on a very defined Pathway to be
doing probably 15 to 18 000 a month off
the laundromat location how much of that
is profit um so off the coin op laundry
it's a much higher margin business than
um
then uh coin I I figure the coinop will
get ten thousand dollars eight to ten
thousand dollars a month the net on
that's going to be like
you know standard standard rule was on
margins like 40 net so two 40 percent of
like 3 500-ish 3000 off the coinopside
my you've got you've got like a 20
margin on the laundry drop off so that's
gonna be another 2 000 bucks it'll be
fifty five hundred six thousand dollars
but the thing is laundry drop-offs much
easier to scale because then you get
somebody in sales
interesting enough I I was talking to
Cody Sanchez when she came to Ohio real
recently and we I was asking her to
break her laundromat numbers down
because I'd never seen her and break
them down and I found out really quickly
that she makes a killing off laundry
drop off and then her her High
performers were on the west coast which
was interesting I've run into some West
Coast guys that were clearing a hundred
thousand dollars a month off laundry
drop off really yeah they go to people's
homes and they pick up their laundry and
they deliver it it's pretty cool really
nice we should get into that business
Jack the laundromat dropped and excusing
myself from that I do not want to get in
the laundry drop off Graham do you
actually want to do that we call it the
laundromat hour one hour and you just
this guy I'm the exact same as Graham
unfortunately it's like you run and you
stay in your own lane and you you have
these businesses that you're always
running and then you get presented with
this idea and you just want to jump on
it right you're just like so I can make
so much money and it won't be that like
active of income source like you just
want to jump on it but the thing is like
you can it's so easy to like constantly
be biting off yeah Brandon's working
four hours a week here yeah on the
laundry laundromat how many laundromats
do you currently own it's just the ones
I'm looking I'm trying to I'm trying to
I'm kind of like in the background
negotiating three right now I'm trying
to figure out how do I get more of them
because I love my laundromat I love
laundromats period um I had the
opportunity recently to talk to the
president of the coin laundry
Association and he was a really really
cool guy
um and he's like you're making my stupid
phone ring off the hook because of your
tick tocks and stuff like oh it's cool
and I I mentioned I was like I've I know
I've heard that the the resale price has
gone up a lot due to social media
it's more expensive to get into it so
you're a probably indirectly responsible
for the car all laundromats across the
country I was told in no certain terms
by some big people that me and Cody
Sanchez have raised the cost of
laundromats at resale on Biz buy sell
and the other platforms like uh loop net
and whatnot like 25 I was about to say
yeah so I've got people that are trying
to acquire them
um like PE type people and they've
they're really angry at me and I was
like well at least for the operators
again and hire multiple in their sales
yeah so like you're making it exciting
and like sexy to and cool yeah to own a
laundromat I think before I looked into
the laundromat business in 2013 and I
decided against it because of how much
work it was to go down to the laundromat
mixing machines but the the ROI was
really high the stores that I was
looking at was anywhere between 150 to
300 Grand in West Los Angeles and the
biggest issue that I saw was that rents
were really high and I was so terrified
of the rents going up in price yeah and
eventually paying a price it's just like
you'll you can't operate you can't stay
in business yeah I've got a couple
people in West LA right now that I'm
helping with me I'm doing some training
and coaching with them and that's that's
always the killer with laundromats is
you get in
um these poor poor I feel so bad for
them these
non-financially astute laundromat people
when they get in and they buy themselves
a job and that's the last thing anybody
needs to do is buy themselves a
laundromat job I mean we talk about July
to drop off you know for the iced coffee
however you could fold clothes for your
your drop-off business I'm gonna do that
right here yeah you could do that right
here you can make all your guests hold
your laundry so you can up up increase
that 20 margin just a little bit but uh
they these un astute people they go in
they buy themselves a job their
landlords increasing the rent rate some
of those are on 3.5 or 4 escalation a
year yeah and it just you know that
compounding interest and if their
utility rates are going up a lot of
those people they don't increase their
price on their customers enough quick
enough and they just go bankrupt
sucks but then when there's someone
closing down due to distress there's
always an opportunity out of my laundry
a lot of my real estate portfolio was
acquired post real estate crash as the
the values had
hit the lowest level of the trough and I
know a lot of people over coronavirus
just made all the money in the world off
real estate that was bought because of
somebody else's distressed asset so it's
like you know whatever there's a problem
there's always a silver lining yeah for
new investors to take over and someone
with some real estate knowledge I think
goes in and gets a laundromat then it
ends up being a situation where
um if they just get some knowledge in
their head they'd go and negotiate with
the landlord so when you work four hours
a week on that how do you spend that
four hours I did I'm down an hour or two
um it was just going in refilling coins
refilling making sure the floors were
swept sometimes stocking my vending
machines just doing them once around I'm
trying to get away from this quickly as
possible I know it's going to kill my
Watchers but we're probably going to
start taking credit cards really soon
just because I'm at a point with the
business if I don't go in and empty
those quarters which I I love it you
know everybody's like oh he's a kid
child at heart wearing the ducktail
shirt I'm like I love the quarters but
uh third Thursday last Thursday my
bucket both quarters was 75 pounds and I
have to lift it over my shoulders yeah
that's a great check you know it does
but then if someone comes in and I have
that bucket on my shoulders and I twist
around to say you know they have a ski
mask on and do they look really shady or
is it someone with a smile on their face
in big basket colors I I have twisted my
back more than once with that 75 pound
bucket why not just do multiple buckets
instead of 175 just do two at you know
37 pounds that would require some
planning
really yeah that we were planning I'd
have to bring two buckets with me but
why do you do that I don't know that
makes it harder Graham this guy wants to
work well really it's because I'm trying
to lift and manage one bucket with a
phone in my hand or do something silly
for YouTube but the thing is like so you
guys tell me I'm wrong here I'm content
I'll do we'll do a consultation right
now is it going to be worth the effort
for me to have multiple buckets in a
video or is one going to be enough take
multiple buckets makes it seem like more
okay you've got to get multiple buckets
like the ones that you've seen where
it's like a bucket and then there's a
secret shelf Jack always scheming Jack
I'm not always
consultation I did you know and then
that then viral immediately I got my
money's worth here so I think I'm still
a little confused about the real
inflection point for you between like
being you know impoverished or whatever
and struggling with money to the point
where you're like you're fine with money
I mean you said you started building
websites you were doing real estate
still not fine with money
we've talked about this right the the
the the mentality the scarcity mentality
that'll get out of here with that
scarcity I'm just saying because I've
noticed you have it too and I think
we've talked about this before actually
you and I how you still feel like you
know you could go back to where you once
absolutely why do you feel that way I
don't know I still have like Nightmares
on that like when I like this is weird I
like when I get all my YouTube stats and
like I've had a really bad day and I'm
like not making any money or some
Something's Happened in the company I'm
like oh crap I'm writing a ten thousand
dollar check for this stupid thing man
I'll have like a nightmare they have to
go I'm back in the warehouse it's just
some psychological silly thing I'm not
not that my life's bad or anything it's
just I notice I do still do a lot of
silly little things and it's like I
don't know why
and what will it take for you to finally
feel comfortable with fun like finances
when I build my time machine I figure it
out I'll let you know you think it's a
number that like a net worth number I I
think I really want to build a house
that's like my big thing that I'm
working towards I want to build a house
like my dream house and I think that
maybe I do that and have that in cash
and have that in cash I'm going to put
in a trust and then that way no one can
lean against me no one can do that I
think I'll be fine I think that that's
it but obviously like when you got to
the point of having like a net worth of
like 500 000 or a million dollars
something you're pretty good for the
most part especially being in Southern
Ohio you think so and what could go
wrong let's start there everything can
happen uh because laundromats could be
lawsuit heavy can't they they can be so
the laundromat could burn down with
people inside of it and the court would
say oh that door was blah blah blah you
know we're gonna go after your million
dollars and I've got I had carry heavy
duty and Charles on everything I do like
my laundromats and car washes are three
million four million aggregate so each
each one of those is like 2 million plus
my umbrella on tops another two so I got
like five four million Aggregate and the
but the problem is burns down with a
couple people and then you felt held
liable
um
that's the Wipeout insurance so then
they go to the LLC well what and the LLC
should provide protection but what if
they Compares my corporate veil and they
determine that I well that's why you
have to have insurance on the LLC as
well and I do well yeah that's in my for
money in aggregate okay but they could
wipe out you could have you could be
found negligent in something and if I'm
like Ohio's not that litigious but I
won't worry about the worst so they
could you know 10 million dollars oh
gosh then they wipe out all these
different things and I've got equity in
some of my llc's and then I'm a sole
proprietor on other ones and then some
have debt with banks I'm purely debt
free it's a mix I've tried to do a
little bit of every kind of real estate
deal I got businesses and real estate
and I got these laundromats and I got
the YouTube channel and I got all just
all sorts of different things and I'm
just trying to build money pockets all
over the place and in the hope that I'll
feel better about it yeah still not
there yet but that point where you
finally did like I said hit those
Milestones of like 500 000 or a million
or something like that what was the
actual Catalyst for you to achieve that
goal because I want to know for the
people listening right okay yeah what
they could do like maybe sure it didn't
still feel like a lot to you but I'm
sure there's someone listening they're
like they're like man how do I do that
how did Brandon do that it was it was
buying the first rental property that
was it was that yeah I felt so good
after I bought the first thing because I
I knew I got the money
buy a place that would make me money I'm
like I can do this again because you
always hear the first one's always the
hardest the first rental is their
hardest as a real estate agent the first
deal of the artist it's always the
hardest one and like if I was to give
advice for everybody it's no different
than you guys should I I had people how
many people this week have had asked you
need to try you need to do whatever it
takes to learn about house hacking you
need to find a place with an FHA loan
you need to get that and for me if I
starting all over again or I was at 18
years ago and I'm like two camera guys
out there they're a 21 22 I'm like you
have to house hack and one of them is
they bought a condo in Myrtle Beach and
I'm like super proud of them and
um Noah the other one that's out there
somewhere
um he's he we were talking about
duplexes like I found duplexes and these
different things that's like that would
be my thing but I would recommend
everybody do and I'm not saying I I
guess I should say I don't think I'm
telling you you have to do this but I
think that is the easiest thing for
anybody to do out there because it's
three and a half percent down you don't
have to have a super insane credit score
to get it I think it's going to be
approachable for a lot of people not the
only thing you can do there's a lot of
other things you do but I think it's the
easiest hanging fruit so basically find
a property that you know you'll be able
to afford and if you need to move in
other people to support the income or
the the expense of having the property
yes
I think that's a wonderful thing and for
you that worked out tremendously and yes
you first felt like you were at least
doing okay when you bought that property
and what I was trying to get out earlier
was the active income of that year when
you bought that property how much was
your active income oh probably twenty
five thousand dollars twenty five maybe
30. and then how much did you make from
that property in appreciation and the
work that you put into that property
like over what time period uh over over
a year or how long did it take uh 75 000
in equity
um first year of rental income was
twelve thousand dollars that's a really
good income oh it's great thousand
dollars a month when you're making 25
Grand a year yeah holy mackerel and how
long did it take for you to actually
complete that process with that house uh
four months
four months yeah so in four months you
made I guess what was that seventy five
thousand dollars yeah and you were in
equity right when you were used to
making twenty five thousand dollars a
year with active
income also a good time to buy them full
time it was but the big thing is it's
like I it's not that to me I'm more the
the mindset there's always a good time
to buy as long as you pre-qualify your
rent house the right property I have uh
someone in my family they bought out
rental in the absolute technical peak of
the Central Ohio market which was April
2007. they never lost money on it yeah
their Equity got wiped out but it was
Cash flowing 300 bucks a month through
the entirety of the downturn and the
Foreclosure crisis and still making that
300 a month they've never raised the
rent on their tenant the tenant's been
in there
uh starting probably 29 2009 so 14 years
they've been making that 300 a month and
you know I I had helped that family
member get a place I was like oh I gotta
get one of these two but uh they did it
through uh subprime all day financing
you know liar loans we just signed a
piece of paper I was like boom you get a
you get a mortgage yeah and that dried
up in late 07 early 08. and what are
your thoughts on the current market I'm
curious because I'm at the point now
where my goal was to buy a house this
year but I I don't know if it's gonna
happen my goal was to actually buy a
house last year but yeah it definitely
didn't happen I I was so scared of the
market and I had people like Graham and
people like my dad that were like you
know you should hold off for right now
it seems like that you know the rates
are high and the prices haven't really
adjusted for the higher rates and prices
were starting to decline and I know a
lot of viewers are probably in my shoes
right now where like buying a house is
still a no joke investment for me like
that's a huge thing yeah and I don't
want to like that could be a crucial
error if I make the wrong you know
purchase at least timing wise what do
you think about the market yeah I mean
the it well number one real estate's
local I'm not from Las Vegas I'm from
the Columbus Ohio market our market
prices have not gone down hardly at all
uh December was I think the best
December we've ever had in history in
terms of volume no appreciation or no
still appreciation from December 2021
but in flat compared to October November
um I I keep pulling on my last data
because I still have my license and I go
get get it right off the market and it's
our markets in Ohio is still very strong
but then again we got 100 billion dollar
Intel chip plant coming to town and it's
just that's going to keep my market
strong if I was in Phoenix Arizona with
the tsmc plant I probably wouldn't be
too gun shy about it I don't know about
the Las Vegas market and what your
employment drivers are and you know is
it casino and Hospitality heavy if if
the casinos make a lion share of income
over there then I might hold off if I
wanted to buy in Austin Texas yeah
prices have gone down a decent bit but
then again you've got Disney building
you've got Tesla building you've got
other I was thinking they they were
talking about our chip some other
company was talking about a chip that
maybe Samsung but there's other drivers
potentially of employment in the central
Texas area and with their business climb
I'm like ah I I wouldn't be super
bearish on buying there if I wanted to
buy like in Los Angeles or San
Bernardino or Orange County I'm like oh
Grant I don't know what their their
economy drivers are but I would probably
be really careful in those areas and
then you know there's so many sub
markets in the United States I worry in
Vegas and you've seen this when you
drive around the amount of construction
right now it is absurd yeah so many
units like just as you're driving in on
the 15 there are thousands of units and
they get finished like every week so you
think the supply is going to climb too
fast oh yeah there's so much like an
under construction right now and they're
not gonna pause the mid I mean so if
they could afford to pause
mid-construction just wait like I think
Toll Brothers is one of those where they
could just choose now you know we're not
going to build right now we'll return
later they can afford to do that a lot
of these other builders they have loans
they have
um you know deadlines that they have to
meet they have to get them built and it
might take a bit of a loss on some of
that I don't know they might offer
really crazy concessions so if you're
talking about for a rental I just think
there's so much new Supply coming on the
market I think rents half the drop yeah
substantially and and once again real
estate's local in Columbus Ohio they've
just there's not enough house being
built right now they just cannot get
them built and I've got developers in my
part when I live 20 miles south of uh
downtown well Columbus area-ish and
they're fighting now there's three
separate develop developers trying to
build four to five hundred home
subdivisions in my my local community
and they're go and we're having zoning
meetings and stuff every couple weeks it
seems because they've got to build more
houses so once again
real estate's local so from for people
not from Southern Ohio or Vegas or LA or
the other places we've discussed what
are some of the biggest indicators that
you look for let's say if you're these
random people like what advice would you
give to them to look for job growth
there's a lot I'm trying to think of
what agency in the federal government
um it's not case Schiller but it's
somebody else they have a heat map a
really good heat map of What markets are
going to appreciate what Market's going
to appreciate and they had different uh
Pro interest rate scenarios different
employment scenarios and I would I would
want to find a place place with good job
growth I also won't want to see a place
that climbed in value obscenely over
coronavirus Because unless there was a
lot of job growth and it's kind of built
on just cheap interest cheap cheap money
in that case where they're pulling the
cheap money off the market you're
probably going to come down but then
there's also a lot of repositioning in
the United States which to me I would
have a little more faith in Vegas than I
would other markets
um so I would want to see job growth
over the past you know two years I'd
want to see you know maybe some Rising
household incomes some migration to that
area and then the other thing I wanted
to say too is I I really feel like if
you're in any Market you could make a
deal meaning you don't have to go out
and buy a new build home off of a
builder you could find something that's
a little run down you could find a house
that needs a little bit of work the
markets I'm in it just seems to me that
a lot of people especially especially
owner occupants they there's a decent
bit of discount on properties still if
you can go in and do a little bit of
work that would be a good opportunity
for you jack waiting just imagine
waiting like four to six months seven
months kind of for the market to settle
a little bit and find a dump you could
go in and spend maybe like 30 40 Grand
just renovating it that would be a fun
project yeah it's going to drive content
will drive you crazy though you think so
yeah oh yeah I would be nervous to like
split any of my focus you yeah you buy
yourself I want to say a full-time job
for or probably four months that would
be
it's a lot you will be there every day
guarantee it yeah
but you could learn to manage other
people that's true and you get
experience in real estate you get the
content and I think it might make you
just a better investor so some good
advice so definitely think about that
let's talk about your portfolio right
now sure because like we've mentioned
it's comprised of a bunch of different
businesses we talk about ass or I guess
like the the worst assets I was gonna
say but like I I should have said like
you know if we're drawing a pie of your
net worth yeah what uh what do the
pieces look like do we want to do social
media too or no well you can't like
evaluation of a YouTube that's fine
because it's like one of those things I
want to be transparent with people but
then I don't also want to overload
numbers so like real estate-ish uh six
seven million ish
um laundromat the car wash we're doing
really good I'm hoping for like a two or
two point two million valuation on it
soon
um we're in the process I'm gonna what I
was on the last one we were talking
about how are are just in the process
just got a new car wash rebuilt we're
just probably a third through the
renovations will end all Renovations
February so we'll this February so in a
month-ish I don't know when the video
dropped but like we'll end up uh that
I'm shooting for like a two to two point
two million dollar valuation in in this
market for it
um laundromats and vending machines and
everything else
um then that probably just everything
else is a million dollars for it's still
almost like nearly 10 10 million 10
million yeah and then I I owe probably
2.5 million dollars to Banks and debt
and everything it's not like that no it
sounds like it's just like a 7.5 million
dollar net worth if you want to do those
numbers so and what about income can we
talk about income yeah it's really hard
because I spend so much I spent so much
money on my YouTube channel this year or
last year 2022 and I spent so much money
on redoing my portfolio the rental
business my whole real estate thing
because we started flipping some of my
rentals into probably 1.3 1.4 Million
last year gross not net if we would take
the income like what should Brandon have
put in his pocket of the 1.2 1.314 1.3
1.4 million I probably cleared 400 000
last year but then I just turned right
over and put it back in more Properties
or upgrading the other ones so it was a
lot less than that then all my uh small
businesses and stuff together I'll give
you the together number because I don't
want to I've got an NDA on the car wash
so I still can't talk about my gross and
net on it because I respect my business
partner he's a great guy but we'll lump
all the other business income in
together
um it probably did
for fifty five hundred thousand dollars
in my vending machines Car Wash
laundromats kind of there's little small
side hustles that I might do do little
funny videos on so that puts me at the
uh
basically oh well that would post me
like 1.8 million gross oh yeah
and then the Nets then that's probably
500 there and did you include YouTube on
that no YouTube last year was a hair
over five hundred thousand dollars
so um but I I haven't done my YouTube
numbers yet to figure out what that net
was because I've been spending so much
money on
cameras crew infrastructure I've got a
video studio now
um I started doing a lot of coaching and
training in the background with people I
spent a lot of money on that I never
thought I'd mention about kind of
looking towards making trying to figure
out how do I help people last time and I
was like oh just make a course and I'll
just put it out there and everybody'll
love it and it's like oh no that costs a
lot of money so I spent a lot of money
on that
um but it's that comes out from a 500
000 social media money too what I find
to be pretty cool is that you've
consistently been able to just put out
profitable businesses like the car wash
the laundromat you have vending machines
you did that paintball thing when you're
a kid real estate but YouTube well well
the the the the the mobile paintball
business failed but it the the other
business oh yeah they're flipping
repairing paintball guns it it was
successful but eventually it failed I
had a website business that I rolled up
and I sold for fifty thousand dollars in
2012-ish but then I had two or three
other little website businesses that I
don't talk about a ton they failed
that's why I say that 2010
09 10 11 12-ish were really tough they
were really tough we had two kids
um we had a website business real estate
income was doing bad like did I ever
really was I Really Ever super
successful as a real estate agent doing
sales and not really I might have made
my AGI on that might have been 20 000 a
year after all my bills were paid
not really that great
um so it's like
all my profitable business get all this
attention and then I do put content out
about the ones that failed and they do
really poorly so I love doing podcasts I
love talking to people because then it's
longer format and I can actually say
yeah I had a paintball business and I
made forty dollars over fixing people's
equipment that would mail in and I would
flip it and then in this other box other
thing I made three bucks an hour
traveling all over Southern Ohio it's
too stupid to understand the difference
between these two stupid me I bought a
laundromat without doing two laundry
mats without doing due diligence from a
guy I lied to me and we had an electric
system explode
um you know
having said that my win ratio on these
businesses definitely getting better
laundromat I bought in April 2019 my
successful one and now I bought it we're
doing eight thousand dollars a month I'm
on a clear pathway to fifteen thousand
dollars a month so over three years from
that point to this point it's great when
I went and bought my car washes we're
proper from day one because I knew what
to look like look at from a cash-based
business that required a lot of work I
took a partner on with that one that
could fix things rather than me trying
to fix it he knows the difference he
knows how to crimp a copper pipe right
and he he's a great guy and knows how to
fix soap tanks and do all sorts of crazy
things so I'm getting better at these
businesses they're becoming way more
profitable and for me what I'm trying to
do is just be transparent on honestly
show people the process so with all the
failures and successes that you've had
in business it's safe to say you're
pretty experienced right I I would say
that but I find out every week There's I
have a new life experience what's last
week's life experience uh digging around
digging out a dead bird from a soap tank
in my car wash it's amazing how did that
happen what is a soap tank so there's a
we have a mixing system in our car wash
someone left the top of it up and
um like an employee employee did yeah
and and uh some bird got in our
mechanical room like maybe it flew in
when someone propped the door open so
they could bring in bags of salt for the
softener or they're bringing in a drama
soap or who knows what and it could have
nested up there and it fell in an open
soap tank with water I probably went in
there thinking it was water probably
nice drink and then maybe just yeah it
was a soap tank but it was the clear
tire shine I think so I was like oh gosh
like do I really want to do this I
thought well I'll put on Instagram and
I'll show people that still do this crap
I reach down the subject what's your
experience been like running a car wash
I I really enjoy it it with laundromats
you deal with a low end clientele most
the time who are struggling to pay their
bills and I I spent a lot of time in the
laundromat you know talking to people we
did like we did we really tried to
clickbaity video and it didn't do as
well as I wanted we filled my um
vending machine full of money so you go
up to the vending machine I had hundred
dollar bills on there so for a dollar
you could get 100 bucks back let's try
and try to do a Mr Beast deal at a
company sponsor me they gave me a bunch
of money I was like oh we're gonna do
that so cool and my crew was there and I
would come over to them and I would say
hey what do you think of this and they
were like this this can't be wrong I was
like I should you know I'd whisper in
there like I should I'm shooting content
for YouTube it's free money just get it
and then half the people just broke down
and were crying and they would give me
these stories of what was going on with
like oh I we came here to do our laundry
because we live in a car I'm like
that breaks my heart and then I'd have I
hear these stories all the time and you
know I get to feature some of them some
cool stories from laundromat but then
the car wash it's all mid to high level
clientele I have people coming in with
rolls royces like where'd you find this
thing it was a 1980 Silver Spur Edition
Rolls-Royce they're not terribly
expensive their knob is a cool car great
car right they're cheaper than a Toyota
Prius
just the maintenance could be a lot I
get it yeah it was it was cool all
leather and stuff and I see stuff like
that we got several guys in town with
Porsches and hiring Corvettes I think we
got a guy with an R8 in town and he
comes to use my car wash I take pictures
of their cars I got a guy with a really
nice Hellcat too like oh cool Southern
Ohio cars that's nice and so it's a
different world I'm dealing with a mid
to high level client that I have mid to
high level problems some lady swiped
their credit card and didn't charge it
properly so she was bad-mouthing me on
Facebook because the credit card swiper
didn't take or something silly like that
there's problems with it but then the I
get a deal with a different clientele
and then with real estate you know as I
move to these higher end properties and
deal with some doctors and nurses and
peer stories for my manager because the
last time in this time I think I don't
think I have my manager so I got a girl
that's a manager and like personal
assistant she sits and helps and assists
my clients because I've got to step away
from the real estate stuff too
just because the day-to-day stuff and
that's helping me with my portfolio
reposition selling off my low end stuff
getting higher and stuff
so how much time do you spend at the car
wash I'm on a mandated thing four to
five hours a week for my partner I just
said we I want to buy this and I'm going
to help you four hours a week and my
YouTube content was doing good
but now I mean my contest continued to
do good but I'm at an inflection point
with my brand I'm like what is my
channel is it physical side hustles
where I go out and I'm like showing
people how I restock vending machines
and stuff like that and I want to trade
stay honest and true I'm like because I
don't stock that anymore I have a girl I
pay 20 bucks a week and she stocks it
for me am I in the the car wash
refilling soap all the time yes I am
currently because I signed a car I
agreed with my business partner that I
would do that and I'm trying to stay
honest and true with him and now it's
like okay well I could buy out that
contract and I could work it's all the
car washes and I could go do something
else I'm trying to figure out what the
next time looks like I'm at a point I've
got to start buying my time back which
for me I'm getting a better brand Focus
I'm like okay now I need to show me
buying my time back and showing them
that I've been these aren't jobs I mean
they're not jobs because they don't have
to be there I want to be there I want to
produce some content but I'm also
getting Equity I'm getting research
residual income I don't see I feel like
your audience isn't at the point of
buying back their time like the people
who are watching your videos are the
type to be beginner yeah want to do the
things to get them to the spot where
they could even own something and then
to show that like okay here's how I'm
buying my time back is too advanced to
advance for most people to comprehend
when they're at the like when they're
trying to get to step one and you're
step ten you're like let me show you how
to get to step 11. yeah pay this person
to do that it's I feel like that's Step
Zero to five it's like the most
impactful for people that want to like
make that change and make that
difference yeah I agree with you I'm not
gonna I'm not going to disagree with you
but I'm also trying to figure out how do
I present that to people
when it's not what I'm doing I've you
know my vending machines are making
three or four thousand dollars a month
that's cool I mean that's life-changing
money for so many people out there I
know you know when I had the paintball
business an extra 500 bucks a month man
I would have killed for that back then
special especially when I was working at
the warehouse yeah or even more 500
bucks a month back then 11 25 an hour
but it's also how do I present that to
my subscribers even though that's not
something I would do teach somebody else
how to do that and document that I think
that would be so cool to take someone
who's uh you know 18 to 25. that's a
good idea has 10 grand saved up five
grand and you walk through with them and
you film it going from nothing to I
don't know 100 a week or something like
that like 500 a month would be insane
and then you get to see the difference
of the work that you do and showing
somebody how to do that like seeing the
excitement yeah that's a good idea I
guess I'm trying to do that with Noah
that's out there he's an intern I
started I got my video studio is
actually out of college so I've been
kind of working the business school out
there to try to find people that are
somewhat talented I'm I'm really having
a problem finding good talent with
people
um I've got my my team keeps getting
better better and better but every so
all pretty often I've had people throw
me curveballs I'm like okay I got to
make sure the people I'm partnering with
are good and then I need to make sure
they're local and I need to make sure
they're they're honest and trustworthy
and true because there are people that
have been helping in the background in
my community with vending machines I
bought one kit well and this this will
never be posted like I'll never go into
that like body kid a couple vending
machines I said I will do some cold
calling for you we documented the cold
calling they never placed them
which I guess that'd be a good video
but once again I'm from rural Ohio do I
really want to post a video about a kid
that I tried to help
went out bottom two vending machines
went through the whole process did cold
calling identified a couple locations he
could play so they never went and got it
done do I post a video on social media
and run the kid down probably not no
what good is going to come from that
yeah I don't think anything's good going
to come from and I've never mentioned
that before other than here so Graham
staff and iced coffee are exclusives
exclusive as exclusive so it's like how
does that work well then I've got a
iterate and build my process down on
helping other people
what that's exactly what I'm trying to
do with some laundromat guys that I'm
coaching and training and we're texting
back at night back and forth almost
every night and presenting offers and
things and I'm really enjoying doing
that level of help and we just
um I think we're going to do a video
project out in Georgia here real soon
where I've been coaching this guy back
and forth for six months now he was
telling me he's so excited he sent and
he had accepted all from a laundromat
and that's a dump it's worse than mine
and I told him I said
you know what if when you buy your first
laundromat and after I've coached and
trained you I said I'm bringing my film
team out and I want to just sit there
with you for the first three days and
we'll go with you over everything you
need to fix this laundromat up and I'll
help
and we'll just film the whole flipping
thing with my crew and because we've
already got all the documentation for
him sending in letters of intent he's
gone through eight like 12 laundromats
looking at it that's where I'm wanting
to take my brand because then it's less
about me and my businesses and it's more
about other people and how can I provide
you value to them so how would you start
let's just say you're I don't know 18 to
25 18 to 30 and you want to make an
extra thousand dollars a month thousand
dollars a month no we got to make more
appetizing than that no I think a
thousand a month is is both realistic 18
to 20 year old yes rate yeah you think
that's a little I think I think in high
school sure a thousand bucks no no side
hustle it's really good money a thousand
dollars a month for a side hustle jacket
yeah it depends it depends on where you
live and how how low income you are 500
a month is life-changing money for
somebody that's making clear like
bringing in 1600 a month at McDonald's
so I mean like I always like trying to
find these things a little bit better
but if I was like a 18 year old kid
fresh out of college or fresh out of
high school and I'm like I'm looking at
maybe going to college I've got a job or
maybe I'm not got a job I would get a
job I would number one started doing
broad range of stocks vtivo
um just find one of those things and I
would start really researching are there
any vending machine opportunities and
this isn't a network and this is not a
organized list
you know your results May Vary
issue a disclosure look at vending
machines can I find some locations for
vending machines can I find some cheap
vending machines on Facebook Marketplace
that's usually my place but once again
we got the Cody Sanchez problem I
mentioned that in videos and all vending
machines disappear
Marketplace but usually if you wait wait
it out a couple weeks you can find one
decent can I find any locations to put a
snack machine or a vending machine well
that's 800 bucks you should be able to
make a couple hundred bucks
um am I tech savvy
um do I like technology I run a lot of
guys they're very passionate about
phones and stuff I like I really like
rebuilding cell phones and computers and
stuff not building gaming computers if I
had a dollar for a buy that asked me
that because once again we're still 18
year old kid
um man I know a lot of kids that could
do a physical side Hustle non-passive
50 bucks an hour doing cell phones so
you work 10 hours a month on fixing
other people's cell phones it's not
really high-end it's not really
technically complicated but if you're
passionate about technology if it comes
over easy 10 hours and 10 hours a month
that's extra 500 bucks and it's scalable
and that way
um I mentioned this in one video I'm not
telling everybody and their brother do
it but we talked about laundry drop off
I've got this kid
um who watched my Tick Tock it tick
tocks and I mentioned you know just be
creative when it starts to you start a
business you know you could do laundry a
draw and do drop-off service without
having any business of your like no
Lottery your own just cut a deal with a
laundromat owner ask for a cheaper usage
of their laundromat and he sent me an
email and he's like I watch a video you
post something like I post that video
two years ago and he's like I'm trying
to buy a laundromat now because me and
my college friends are making 7 500 8000
7500 8 000 extra month and they're using
too many machines in the laundromat
they're trying to get kicked out so like
how to put an alarm at wow so they don't
have to have any of their own equipment
they just say we'll do the laundry the
labor the little writing will take a
split of what you bring in yeah and wow
and and doing all this I would um I
would build a brand so if you want to
fix cell phones it's time for you to
learn to make a Facebook page you want
to do vending machine place placement
learn how to do an email signature and
build a Facebook page for your vending
machine learn cross train and learn how
the business World works and then you
know I still want to turn people away
from buying seeing if you can do a house
hack what's the scariest moment you've
had at one of your own laundromats uh my
laundromats are becoming period the
company
I had to pull a gun on somebody you had
to pull a gun
um there was a rumor that there was a
guy that had murdered somebody and he
was squatting in one of my trailers
and the videos actually I mean the
videos on YouTube but I edited
everything out and I'm like you know
might have been better to post on the
internet I don't well no no the reason I
didn't post it was because I was still
worried about the guy I went and did a
video and that's when I filmed 99 of my
stuff with a cell phone and I was doing
the hey it's Brandon with investment Joy
selfie and there was a guy's legs in a
room and I didn't go I I do walk there's
all my houses before I film now like I
make sure the location's secure before I
turn the camera on and uh I didn't do it
that time I was a bad mistake so I
turned around and I saw legs
and I'm like what the crap and I look
and there's like
window in the trailer smashed out blood
across the wall no and he gets up I'm
like hello sir he's like don't mind me
I'll leave and I gotta look at his face
and it's the guy they said you know he's
got a murder warrant in Kentucky
crap
so I do my thing I pull the gun on my
holster and I'm like okay I'm ready to
go
and I got the camera I don't know if it
was recording at that time I know I've
got video
through that incident and I'm like you
need to leave my trailer park right now
just get out here I don't care where you
go never want to see you here again and
you know he had a very violent guy and
he's I'm sorry I'm psyched like you know
bud I feel for you
um but this is my trailer park you can't
live here you're not paying rent I can't
run anything to you I wish you best of
luck but you've got to leave
um you know everybody from my company
knows I'm here
and if you don't leave within two
minutes I'll call the cops and you we
both know you don't really do that right
now and he walked off and we still dealt
with that guy a couple times but not in
that capacity so that's been weird but
that was 2019 that's pre-coronovirus
that's pretty wow YouTube Fame and stuff
like that so it's like okay ever since
then it's like okay I need to be worried
about that a little bit more but I'd try
and be you know it's a refining process
and try to get a little better a little
better a little better do you always
carry that's the time yeah okay it's a
crazy situation it's it's it's life but
a lot of people have you ever considered
like wearing a bulletproof vest or like
just something where it's you know okay
penetrable or a bull Professor I mean if
someone pulls like a like a knife or
something like that
yeah maybe wear something that I mean to
me to me here's the thing to me if it's
that bad it's probably time for me to
hang it up because I've got a wife and
five kids right but it's it's also one
of those things where I also feel on the
other end I really need to document this
process of my life and going on
um just just going through the process
it's important because you know a lot of
people that have got a lot of kids in
the ghetto and they're like you don't
know what it's like to live up in this
environment you know people getting shot
every day yeah you know I've been in
some tough times too and allows me on at
least one level to connect with some of
my subscribers that aren't in a
traditional life situation and I I feel
like it's important I feel like I can
talk about it as time goes on as my
brain gets bigger and better then I can
go back and reflect and talk about the
stories and talk about the bad times the
good times how much money I've made how
much money I haven't made how successful
my businesses are or have been how
unsuccessful they are and I'm just
trying to craft stories around these
different situations and you know trying
to make the best of it because I think
there's always value and positive and
negative situations kind of defines a
person you know how did you respond to
this thing well didn't respond to the
paintball company very good when we were
making three bucks an hour he didn't
iterate and improve it that went
bankrupt or closed down or whatever it's
just you know uh it is what it is but
I'm very thankful for this you know if
you feel thankful feel blessed for this
point in life with my social media
um brand I've met some people that you
know they're like you changed my life I
watched that video and like I have one
video like 3 500 people watched back in
2019 where I was just talking about
it doesn't matter where you are where
you live whether you're in LA or the
Deep South you can make a difference of
your own life like you can change the
situation you're in and I would
encourage you I'm not telling you what
to do I'd like you to consider starting
a business or developing a business
mindset and everything you do and the
this guy
um is adult now said oh that just
changed my life because I was in college
for some crazy degree that had no future
and he said and it was it was something
in the Arts he said it's not that I um
I I I you you I took your advice I said
oh you hate Arts that's it in the video
which he understood he got that out of
it and he said but I changed my major so
I'd had an art degree I majored in
business immediately
I was like okay cool and he said so the
first thing I did as a business school
project is I started developing a brand
and um they ended up by the time he got
out of college they got acquired
I was like oh
dang it that's cool and I'm like well
how much did you guys get acquired for
because it was a decent sized brand to
cut somebody that kind of heard it I was
like is it more than 5 million or less
than 5 million I said
yes I can't say exactly I said more than
5 million the kid shakes his hat and wow
yeah
it's nice for a video that I felt
disappointed on no one watched 3 500
views 3 500 views in 2019. see I'm
always surprised by who listens to these
podcasts like sometimes I get DMS from
the most random people it blows my mind
I just got a guy and um he's like oh I'd
love for you to help me with Rosie I
said I do I do training coaching like I
will give you it for free just do it
he's in the NBA
um I've got another guy and he was he's
kind of not a major character but he's
minor character on stranger things like
everybody really yes oh I'll tell you
I'll tell you off camera okay
um really nice guy and he's he he's been
texting me while I've been in Vegas
because he's like I got a real estate
deal and there's some
distressed situations there he's such a
sweet guy such a cool guy what is this
world I'm in so cool yeah and I'm like
what world am I in that people would
have any
they pay any attention to this guy
that's never going to college I'm from
Southern Ohio grew up poor and I've just
been trying my best and I'm you know I I
fail in a lot of things and I walked
there watch playing videos oh that's a
stupid video why did they publish it oh
man we could have done a better
thumbnail I'm like but man I'm having
some sort of positive impact on the
world I'm like I need to keep doing it
um trying to keep myself safe but I'm
also trying not to live a lifestyle
where I insulate myself from everything
that happens
and you know maybe maybe I'll die on
camera and get a lot of clicks or maybe
I'll just keep keep going on and
everything will be fine I am trying to
be cautious though yeah I got a random
question do you think that it's easier
to build wealth in rural areas or like
the Midwest or do you think in wealthier
areas like high density uh places like
L.A I think it's totally equal you think
it's perfectly I think it's perfectly
equal I think it's just 50 50 and I
think the problem is
the problem is with the Midwest and
Rural America is it's hard to find local
mentors easily because there's not an
easy Brain Trust that you can find super
quickly I mean there's a method to it
I'm big on good old boys clubs like the
Masons or the Eagles or the moose or Odd
Fellows or fraternal organizations for
old people like I love those things
um
I love those types of groups in the
midwest when you go to a place like La
you could find you know they've got
these incubator meanings I know I've
seen some like nft meetups here in Vegas
and I've seen the people that go to them
I'm like man those really cool places
they're big and they're advertised the
uh the opportunity to get a job here and
make a lot of money quick is very very
big the opportunity in the midwest to
buy a company from a dying owner quickly
and easily or you can go and you can buy
cheap real estate and it's just I don't
ever want anybody
uh I watched my content to say this is
what I have to do this is this is how it
has to be you know this you this you you
need to go and buy a vending machine
right now because realistically it's you
know you can get a vending machine and
not make a bunch of money off of it I
like it because it insulates you because
you can wait that you know it's just
resell vending machine for the 800 bucks
you have in it but I just feel I mean so
many successful people from the Midwest
and they do they've done well and people
plenty of people from California do well
um
and you know it's just I think it's just
you have to have a different mindset you
have to understand the market just a
little bit different but I think anybody
can be successful in where you are what
do you think Graham
um I think big cities you you're exposed
to so many other people I think that
helps yeah from what I've seen that the
smaller towns and cities
um people tend to think the same way I
think bigger cities you could break
beyond that easier and at least for for
me in La like just seeing because you
have such a disparity of wealth in L.A
uh you go like one side of the 10
freeway and all the houses are a quarter
the price is going like a mile
you know the other side of the 10
Freeway West of it
um not west north
um I think just seeing that
you're able to kind of pick and choose
from those areas and those those
uh businesses so I think that that helps
is just being around it right we don't
really get quite that elsewhere yeah but
for me it's also just the different I
would I would say that
um I would say based on the knowledge
base and the current thing that
everything works it's probably slightly
easier in a bigger city
um
But as time goes on especially with
social media and the knowledge that's on
YouTube I Love YouTube today and it's
becoming very easy to become very
wealthy in Rural America because that
that knowledge base it just gets easier
and easier I agree I know some of the
the best businesses that you can get
into are the best like jobs that you can
get into at a young age with a little
experience are done on a laptop anyways
yeah so it's better definitely if you're
doing those sorts of jobs to live in
cheaper areas where you can do some
something with your money rather than
like in some part of La where if you
want to get a starter home it's like one
and a half million dollars the strategy
has to be different that's why I'm like
I'm not telling you to get vending
machines in downtown L.A probably would
look at something a little bit different
and a house hacks going to be very very
difficult but you know what I got a guy
in Orange County I know that bought a
vending machine route from a retiring
owner who just couldn't deal anymore is
doing 175k gross 95k net and he bought
it for 80 000 no yeah Orange County
and that's so cool to be doing like I
always think the idea of vending
machines is so nice you literally walk
up with some food you put it inside sure
maybe you need to make repairs yeah and
then you just collect money that sounds
amazing yeah that's great and there's
there's a lot of upside to it and
there's a lot of we just did videos on
one of the Las Vegas's largest ATM guy
that's a cool business
and he is also one of the largest
massage chair guys and I never would
have what okay well tell us about this
massage chairs you ever go to
um uh go through an airport yes and
someone's sitting there they just
dropped a 20 bill I at one time I heard
he had most of those in airports
and uh I always thought those were owned
by the airport I don't think so I think
he's the guy that has a bunch of them
but he started he started rattling off
some locations here in Vegas that he had
massage chairs and ATMs and I think
we're going to do a video on them pulled
like a a standard investment Joy video
so for an ATM it's a reverse video it's
not pulling money from the location it's
putting 15 grand in and then for the
massage chair
um they had a demo model that we were
getting b-roll for so they're like oh we
got the nice light and we're doing High
frame photography on it or high frame
video and we'd get shooting all the
b-roll and prep for tomorrow's video and
then they open it up and they get the
the money cassette out when they pull
like what what where's this money from
they pulled the Cash There's I mean it
looked like there's 80 bucks in there
and they're like this was never in use
or this was like not supposed to be in
use still somebody it was sitting in an
office a commercial office here real
close to your place and just from the
business people transiting through a
small office and they made like 75 to
100 bucks that's crazy yeah I was like
oh we don't have to they were because
they talked about for this b-roll shop
maybe we could take you know let's dump
our wallets in there and see if we can
put like 10 bucks in here just for
b-roll with our lightings rig no
everybody just looked at like holy crap
there's a lot of money in this thing I'm
like wow and this is a testament to
these silly business ideas where you're
buying you know the guy that we did the
videos with Aaron he said yeah I love
buying robot robot employees that I
guess you know I think that he has 700
robot bank tellers ATM machines and he's
got hundreds or dozens of robot
masseuse
Jesus
Medusa yeah he's got all these all these
he's all these different businesses just
so cool like oh my gosh as I get more
into this industry and more people call
me about saying oh you got to see how
I'm making money today and like the kid
that watched me on Tick Tock and got
some value in my business making you
know 7 500 bucks a month I'll folding
other people's clothes like oh my gosh
is this this world has so much
opportunity and if you can solve other
people's problems and if you can find a
way to automate it you make a lot of
money off of it
just wow all right title of the video
how to build a seven figure business in
a month in a month 30 days in 30 days
building a seven figure business in 30
days yeah just gotta listen to Brandon
last question that I have is uh you were
mentioning earlier about hidden
compartments sure you find them all the
time I have found a lot and the coolest
one I ever did and we're one day passed
I I set Chillicothe Ohio where my
laundromat is was on the um Underground
Railroad I have found at least one
compartment house where they were hiding
Refugee slaves and it was that was
awesome wow it was a it was a room in a
closet and a closet and I was like
what the heck it was an old brick
Victorian and
um gosh it was 10 years ago and uh it
was I was like walking Closet in a
Victorian I was like they didn't have
these so I'm walking in and I'm looking
in this this closet I'm like man
and I'm like look at him there's a shoe
compartment like where they had a little
shoe rack in it like these people in
this house in 1850 that was like built
in 1840 like man these people were rich
and I'm looking in this cubby hole and
I'm like
here's a a little
um
a little piece of wood that you could
just turn I was like oh I've seen this
before and it's like you could see where
they could move the shoe rack over and
whatever you flip it in and then the
door just swung open and you open up the
door and it's a compartment
Angelica I think oh my gosh like they
had people here
that's been the coolest compartment I
think I've ever seen I was like did you
film it now this was
this yeah I say I I've documented
everything since 2013. this is one I'm
pretty sure I missed I should probably
go through my records a little more but
most of the ones what we talked about
earlier that's the coolest one but I
also find a lot of drug compartments
people will
um they'll modify their ductwork in
their house they'll pull out their their
Vents and then they'll put
you know they'll hide things in there on
um fishing line and stuff and you're
looking at like oh crap that guy that I
rented this house to that I just loved
to death and they're so kind and elderly
was hiding
hiding substances here and I've seen you
know all these different compartments
and all these different things you the
conversation we had was about a person
that I think had modified cars with
hidden compartments I was like that was
cool growing up you know the James Bond
thing but then when you realize what
most people are dealing with it's not
near interesting as James Bond movies
but um like I've been in I haven't
rented too many cool houses like that I
remember one house and probably when I
was doing bpos they wanted me to do a
BPO in a house and uh just going outside
and I'm like it's a Cape Cod I was doing
my form Cape Cod go inside where's the
Second Story go outside there's a window
out there go inside where's the access
to it go outside there's blinds in a
chair that lamp is antique there's no
access to the Cape Cod the half story up
top they go in the kitchen and I realize
that they've drywalled and trimmed over
the old staircase wow yeah
I was like I can't I can't modify this
house this is
I can't do that so I'm a real estate
agent they paid me 65 dollars to go in
tell me what the house is worth and all
I could do was like check off the Box
possible Cape Cod here's the value with
here's yeah oh and I was like man that
was one of those moments I was like man
how cool would it be to be a real estate
investor buy this house because if it
was uh interior BPO was a foreclosure so
I just didn't to tell them what to
listen for and I was like man I want to
buy one of these house and just go on
treasure hunting
um the closest I've got to that old my
own houses was I bought a house with a
barn the barn had a attic in it and you
know I'm working through this thing I
was like I got one I got one and I'm
working through it you can tell where
the slats and the boards in the Attic
were so bad the roof was old metal you
could see daylight or some some level of
light oh it took me a week to figure out
and I realized on that specific house
that there was it was a Hayloft at one
time and you know with a Hayloft who
cares about them they're just going to
bring a hay track up to it you're going
to push push whatever up in there the
only way to get it was through a ladder
on the outside paint it over little wood
latch just like the house that was
underground Riverwood house
um so I was looking at it and I flipped
that open I I haven't I we had brought
ladders to try to get in it and before
and my crew took the ladders off so I
got on the hood of my or got on the cab
of my pickup truck I had at the time
very perched very precariously lifted it
open and it was full of like Christmas
decorations from the 50s wow yeah so
there's an old antique sleigh in there
and just some other cool stuff that's
pretty neat that's a little better than
the drugs like a really expensive
version of Storage Wars except you're
buying a house yeah I obviously if I get
if I get really screw you money for you
social media that's what I want to do so
I was about make an offer on somebody's
whole state site unseen I want to buy
your farm for 350 000 I don't care
what's in it I'll take it all I've had
offers like that in the past but never
would have had money
um just that'd be cool serious just
bring my team in we find everything
value and we go in and we flip the house
that's cool we'll figure out what all
the contents are worth and what all the
real estate's worth that's what I'd like
to do but that's a 250 350 000 video
project or probably more last time I had
one offered it was pre-coronavirus and
even in little middle nowhere Ohio our
values have gone up a bit so I got a
random question just to just to satisfy
my curiosity how many doors do you have
135 right now 135 do you know what about
you had last time we shot with you uh it
was probably
130 ish so I've already started
consolidation selling the crappy units
trading above for better units so I've
probably bought six or seven much nicer
ones and then sold off dozen crappier
ones and when that those those sales are
reflected in my 1.4 million ish that I
did in did last year in total real
estate volume got it you go yeah thank
you so much for coming tonight Jack
um one other thing I want to mention is
that you could get a free stock when you
said all right guys thank you so much
for coming in thank you so much for
coming on the podcast thousand dollars
with that said you guys until next time
enjoy very cool guys
that's great thank you so much man thank
you